no breaking news right now yep amid the
rumors jennifer lopez and ben affleck
are just friends
oh yeah i mean it's hard to deny
recently news broke that the two have
been spending time together
after j.lo and alex rodriguez called it
quits
but a source tells e.t that jyn and ben
are quote
just friends and have a cordial good
relationship
the source goes on to say quote they
obviously have a romantic history
but at this point they only have a
friendship adding that they quote
both admire each other professionally
respect one another and feel comfortable
with each other
[Music]
benefit took the world by storm when
they got engaged in 2002
later bringing their romance to an end
when they called off their wedding in
2004.
you know we went through a really rough
time in the press and things like that
back in the day
so while the news of jennifer and ben's
reunion excited fans
it's important to note that they've
remained friendly since their split
a second source tells e.t quote that
jennifer and ben have seen each other a
few times since her breakup with alex
stating that they have remained friends
over the years and the two
are still just that friends it's so
important that you model for your kids
how to be a citizen of the world
as for jennifer garner who was married
to ben from 2005 to 2015
a source tells et that quote jyn isn't
bothered by ben hanging out with j-lo or
anyone else
she wants what's best for ben the
49-year-old mother who shares three kids
with the justice league star
is focused on ben being a great dad the
source states quote
they've been in a good groove when it
comes to co-parenting for a while
and their kid's happiness is jin's main
priority
we do our best speculation about jlo and
ben reuniting romantically
comes after his split from anna diamez
in january
and lopez calling off her engagement to
a-rod in april
but jennifer and alex appear to still be
friendly
following their breakup the two were
spotted having dinner at the hotel bel
air in los angeles a source told et that
the exes arrived
separately and left separately noting
that quote the dinner did not appear to
be a romantic situation
can we give it up for a-rod please
meanwhile as a single man alex has taken
to instagram to show off his physique
he shared side-by-side photos of him
from december until now
adding the caption quote left the dad
bod in 2020.
in 2018 the former baseball star gave
e.t a little insight on his workouts
with j.lo
and how he stays fit well jennifer
always kicks my butt
but she's a great dancer she loves it as
well
look i think the combination for me is a
hybrid of barry's boot camp
and and yoga and hot yoga and i think
the fact that you can work on your
flexibility your strength your core
and do it in a group environment it's
great and when you're done you get your
green juice
right at the center